[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by taissa farmiga
aka gladys russell in the gilded age
which premieres on hbo monday how you
doing today taissa i'm pretty fabulous
to be honest how are you doing
i'm doing great so i absolutely love the
show i'm excited for everyone to watch
it and what i love in particular is your
portrayal of gladys because it's a
character that is just so reserved and
it's a restrained performance that's
really good with good posture and
there's this properness to her so
is that harder to play though would you
say than playing someone who's like
eccentric
um
you know again everything's gonna have
its ups and downs i think um
you know i think gladys's naiveness and
and
she can have
a bit of a hint of shyness and and
and
you know just being slightly sheltered
and being under her mother's her
mother's um
wing you know her mother doesn't want
her to to flourish and grow up and and
get out in the world unless it's the way
that bertha wants um you know i think
that
i really related to gladys's desire to
break free of her mother's expectations
of her and and growing up in a house of
sometimes seemingly arbitrary rules and
why does this have to be this and i
think it's it's
um yeah you know
the fact that she's so restrained in the
beginning i think it's fun because it's
like she has such a
there's such a potential journey for her
to go and you're ready over season one
you see her blossom quite a bit by the
end of it and even so in that regard
it's only a little bit if you if you
look at the big picture so i think
there's i think it's fun to start from
maybe a more closed off space because
the journey is what's going to be very
exciting
yeah and like you're mentioning i love
that it kind of goes at this slower pace
and a natural realistic way to see
someone kind of change and i love you
mentioned your mother in the show bertha
who's played by carrie [ __ ] how did you
guys approach that relationship because
it's a pretty cold one from her how did
you and carrie come down in the same way
i mean carrie was just was just was just
busting my balls the entire season
anytime something went wrong anytime
anything like that
oh it's taito what time where's tai you
sleep we're waiting for ty you know what
i mean um she's just honestly she's one
of the most amazing human beings i've
ever met and um i don't i don't have
enough positive words to say about her
she's phenomenal as an actress but also
just as a human being she's one of the
kindest people i met but also being
just just unapologetically herself and
it's really it's really beautiful to to
watch it's also beautiful to be a part
of and her chemistry with morgan specter
who plays george my father is just
incredible it kind of made my job easy
when i was in the scenes because you
just you just get to feed off their
energy
yeah and i think that's what people are
going to be excited about just watching
this russell family and how many
feelings we get watching how they treat
each other it's it's fascinating stuff
so yeah i also noticed too with the
character of gladys she's um knitting at
one point and then you even get to like
carry around a parasol like when you're
doing little character details like this
like do you start like seeing how you
could find joy in this like how people
back in the day like are you knitting
now are you into it
i am not i'm not i'm not knitting now i
have knit i haven't in the past my my
older sister beer got me into knitting i
think i once knit myself uh like a
little beanie which i still have and
it's my proud one of my proudest moments
in life um the current day has not
picked up knitting or embroidering from
from from gladys but um yeah i mean it's
fun it's all those little details it's
it's something that i would never
experience in my life as high so i'm not
a i'm not a parasol kind of girl i'm you
know what i mean like okay
like
i mean
yeah you know i'd rather you know i'd
rather be like sweaty digging up some
plants in the backyard which i don't
think gladys would be totally into but
i mean that's the fun of it you know
what i mean i think that's one of the
biggest draws of this project for me was
being able to step into a world that i
really had no experience with
yeah and that's that's interesting you
mentioned that too because you know
you're mostly known for doing these
great horror and thriller projects so
sure what was something that stood out
to you about doing this period piece
that maybe you liked a little better
than maybe
doing a horror
yeah you know i think it's it's it's
it's
i want to be careful the word better
because it's not better it's different i
think what you get excited about as a
human is new experience it's the same
thing that gladys is striving for you
know what i mean she
wants to venture out in the world and be
independent and and and get out of her
mother's light and or shadow i mean
and um
establish yourself and it's the same
thing for me and my person my personal
life i love new experiences and trying
new things and
um i again as i said i wasn't familiar
with 1880s and the idea of
stepping this world into a world again
i'm not associated with it's very
different than horror story or the nun
or anything like that and
yeah it's nice to grow it's nice to flex
your wings in a different way and try
something new and i i think i definitely
was
was was pushed at times like even just
the working on the dialect with howard
samuelson was our dialect coach like i
was
nervous about it i was like you got to
sound proper you got to watch your
posture you got to do this but at the
end of the day you know the first day
was it was nerve-wracking but then
you're in it and it's just playing
pretend it's just playing pretend
yeah that's really cool to hear and that
it seems like you guys are having fun
doing it and would you say there's
anything you learned about just life in
general from playing gladys something
that may be connected to today through
her character
um
that's interesting i've never i truly
haven't thought of that um
you can say no you could just say no
i was just i was just thinking about no
um
i think it was maybe you know i think
it's
yeah i i feel like to this day i still
have like you know you butt heads with
your parents and and and their beliefs
and what they want from you and things
like that and i think in a way it was
almost comforting being able to play
gladys because it's like oh it's like
it's kind of something you never really
you never really grow out of you know
what i mean you're obviously a
relationship with your parents ebbs and
flows and it grows but i don't know it's
kind of nice to remember that like man
everyone has a hard time everyone likes
butts heads but with their parental
units
oh totally totally and um i have to
mention too because you talked about
american horror story and stuff and
already being known as one of these
amazing scream queens of all time you
look at all these lists online is that a
badge of honor for you or you don't
really like care about that no of course
of course i love it i mean
god my like my horror scream is it's
like i feel like back when like i was
filming that like final girls and horror
story and all that like i didn't realize
how much i loved it but now like yeah my
horror stream is a badge of well
absolutely i don't know how yeah
but also just like the like i love the
like i just picture filming the nun and
it's still like
but whatever something comes out and you
just do that like
i love that i love that hell yeah no
that that's exciting here because like
i'm one of those people's passion about
seeing you in these films and being a
screen yeah
it's cool that you like it too and also
i have to ask this total curveball but
you're a known patriots fan um sorry
sorry about saturday and um
i do want to know though are you a super
fan of football can we put that on the
record is that official um
i
superfan is such a such a hard word i am
i'm a fan of football my um growing up
my parents or my dad um he grew up in
argentina for from 5 to 18 so he watched
um
soccer real real
quick real football
um so it was only once i i started
dating my my partner my now husband um
he was a huge uh football fan and he he
went to college in emerson when um
tom brady was first at the patriots so
that is how i became a football fan
seven years ago i am a huge football fan
i love it because it feels like a game
of chess to me i have a very logical
brain um but super fan i don't know i
feel like i still have a bit more to
learn before i can claim that title
right under it'll be the next one under
scream queen
love it everybody everyone who's a super
fan of taissa check her out in gilded
age this monday watch her absolutely
crush it as gladys russell taissa i just
want to say before they go this was a
dream come true for me uh part of me
doing what i do interviews reviews that
keeps me going in the morning was one
day i hope to interview types for me it
happened so i'm grateful that you talked
to me and i hope to talk to you in the
future one day thank you steve it's my
absolute pleasure thank you i appreciate
your time